[Musique]
c'est un émerveillement permanent
l'union de la vienne et de la loire
l'hiver la rivière et le fleuve se
confondent avec le ciel grisâtre un
spectacle poétique et contemplatif
le clou du spectacle le promontoire
là haut nous retrouvons alain garou
spécialiste de l'histoire locale
quand vous arrivez ici c'est un peu
comme une mise en scène là vous montez
vous montez vous arrivez vous attendez
pas si vous connaissez pas ou on
s'attend pas perspective majestueuse
immense
10 km de profondeur jusqu'à chine ont
jusqu à saumur vous apercevez les
châteaux
quand il fait beau évidemment
alain a grandi au pied de ses remparts
moyenâgeux il connaît chaque recoin de
ce petit havre de paix où l'évêque de
tour st-martin mourut en 371 après jésus
christ
le village les bords de rive la
collégiale au total 2700 44 hectares
sont désormais protégés
et il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir on
n'y a pas de contraintes nouvelles ou au
point de vue du bâti par contre on a une
protection accrue surtout paysage sur
les dix villages qui constituent ce site
classé
en amont sur les bords de la vienne les
amateurs de pêche ont accueilli la
nouvelle avec grande joie ici brochet
perche sandre et silures mordent à
l'hameçon puis sont relâchés quand on
voit un peu la situation géographique
d'où et quand saint martin sur le
confluent de la loire et de la vienne et
que la vienne restent une très belle
rivière poissonneuse et naturel on sent
forcément privilégiés sans hésiter je
préfère la vienne parce qu'elle est bien
plus naturelle et elle est plus étroite
au 6 qui fait que ça donne un espace de
jeu un peu plus un peu plus compliqué
mais technique à pêcher quand saint
martin la confluence de la loire et de
la vienne symbole de la symbiose
parfaite entre le produit de la nature
et l'action de l'homme